jeffrey toobin is leaving cnn
jeffrey toobin you may recall had to
take a brief leave of absence from cnn
after he was caught
how do i put this as a family show he
was caught
being romantic with someone he loves
very much
to use a euphemism of woody allen
he was caught
being romantic with himself
on a zoom call with his colleagues and
so he had to take a little break and
then they just let him right back
cnn led him right back in so i know
bloom has a really funny line neon
taster on twitter he just said jeffrey
tuban is quitting to spend more time
with himself
uh tuban's leaving he says friends i've
decided after 20 years i'm leaving cnn
after my vacation it was great to spend
my last day on air with pals wolfe
anderson and don
love all my former colleagues watch for
my next book coming out from simon
schuster okay
the lesson from jeffrey tubin here
is
you should not
do things that you would not want to
read about
you yourself doing in the new york times
that you would not want to see yourself
doing on television
i know this seems really basic this is
really basic like don't do bad do good
things don't do bad things but it's it's
important to remember because we forget
about it sometimes especially in liberal
modernity where we think that we have
the right to do any sort of bizarre
shameful disgraceful thing that we want
in private just can't do it in public
but we can do it in private and that's
not true you don't have a right to do
bad shameful things in private or in
public
nor macdonald had a whole great bid on
this
roxanna had a great bit about everything
but yes you don't have a right to do
those kind of shameful things in private
but also just as a technological matter
we're almost never in private anymore
we have surveillance devices
everywhere you carry a surveillance
device at least one everywhere you go
that's your phone your phone is
listening to you whether you're you're
actually using it with the screen on or
the screen's off or even the phone's off
it can be listening to you we've got
cameras everywhere in our society
surveillance cameras
in and we use it for security that's
just modern security now is we have
these cameras and it offers a lot of
benefits to us but then the other thing
you've got to consider is you're you're
always being listened to you're always
being watched
and we can complain about that it's got
some downsides to it one of the upsides
is don't do bad stuff it kind of holds
people a little bit more accountable
you don't want to do those things the
other reason to do it
is
we we have a lonely and the other reason
to avoid doing bad things
not to do what jeffrey tubin did is
because
one of the chief
scourges in our country right now
is a loneliness epidemic you see this
crop up on social science survey after
social science survey
people are really really lonely it's
actually destroying the american life
expectancy it's decreasing now several
years in a row for the first time ever
because of deaths of despair because
people are killing themselves they're
doing drugs they're really they feel
isolated and they feel lonely
and not to be too scolding or sound like
the church lady but the thing that
jeffrey tubin did
and got caught doing
that a lot of people do
that is pretty much the loneliest action
you can possibly do
uh when you are uh you know very uh
involved with yourself
a man wrapped up in himself makes a
small package indeed it's the loneliest
thing you can possibly do because
our our bodies
are worth respecting we're trying it's
weird in some ways we think that we're
just entirely our bodies and we're bags
of chemicals and we just poke and prod
ourselves and just try to get whatever
sense of pleasure we can but then on the
other hand in our society we deny our
bodies entirely we say body doesn't mean
anything
my true self is totally different from
my body that's why if i look like a boy
i can really be a girl because my body
doesn't matter
when we go between these two completely
schizophrenic ends
but we're both we're body and soul and
spirit and
the the body is a symbol
of our souls our souls are the
substantial form of our bodies
and so it means we've got to treat our
bodies with respect and our bodies have
natural longings okay the kind of
longings that jeffrey toobin was trying
to satisfy in a way that was not
particularly edifying and that it ended
up destroying his life
but our bodies have natural longings and
we're not supposed to
just deny them
we're not supposed to deny them or even
exactly suppress them i mentioned dante
at the top of the show it didn't even
occur to me to make this connection but
dante is
makes this point and it's such an
important point it's a central christian
point
our our longings our erotic longings or
eros is good it's a gift from god and
we often abuse it to just bring us right
down into the gutter right down into the
sewer i read that story about you know
some guys gave their dog monkey pox
that's pretty that's pretty much the
most disgusting way you can possibly
direct your eros but eros isn't a bad
thing in and of itself and if you point
it in the right direction it will lead
you up it'll lead you straight up to
heaven that's what that's what the
divine comedy is about dante has an
erotic love for a woman named beatrice
and
even though he's he's not married to
beatrice he's only seen her twice or
something and he's only he's only really
met her twice and then she dies
at i don't know
in her teenage years he saw her when she
was nine years old falls in love and she
becomes this
erotic image for him but it's not just
about her it's not just about
stripping beatrice
it's his erotic love for her that guides
him up toward heaven he actually sees
god reflected in her eyes he's looking
at her but she's looking at god and he
sees that that's what we have to do we
have to take our natural longings
and not just turn them in on ourselves
and poke ourselves and prod ourselves
and take a bunch of drugs and stuff our
faces and doom scroll and just stare at
screens all day we've got to take those
natural longings which can be good and
guide them in the right
direction or else we're all going to
become
we're going to do shameful things and
then we're going to be ashamed and we're
going to be embarrassed and you better
hope that you never get caught like
jeffrey toobin does on a zoom call but
why take the chance why do you think
jeffrey toobin's happy did he i don't
think so i don't think he's actually
pleased himself all that much
right now head on over to
goodranchers.com michael our friends
over at good ranchers are on a mission
to donate 100 000 high quality meals
this month to children in need to help
them reach their goal 10 lucky listeners
who purchase a box of my absolute
favorite meat delicious american meat
from goodranchers.com michael will win a
30-minute zoom call experience with me
on september 30th you know what we're
calling it we're calling it a meet and
greet do you get it you better you
better hurry up and sign up right now
this offer is only valid through august
31st buy from
goodranchers.com save 30 on your box of
100 american meat plus free shipping and
be entered to win a 30 minute zoom
session with me off the clock
let's help these guys reach their goal
of 100 000 donated meals this month and
then you and i can hang out in a meet
and greet
and maybe who knows maybe i'll be eating
good ranchers during the meet and greet
i'm not sure all i know is i eat good
ranchers pretty much three times a week
i absolutely adore their meets you will
too head on over goodranchers.com
michael
i'm so glad you liked that clip be sure
now to subscribe get the notifications
ring the bell
right now you can do it we got 1 million
subscribers now it's time
to get a billion
ring the bell we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]